[Musique]
près de cent mille morts depuis
début de la crise sanitaire en france
plus de 5900 personnes actuellement en
réanimation les chiffres de l'épidémie
de coronavirus continue d'inquiéter via
un choix de société qui est un choix
politique qui est d'accepter que l'on
est chaque jour un boeing qui s'écrase
c'est à dire 300 340 décès au brésil où
vivent 2 112 millions d'habitants la
pandémie a fait plus de trois cent
cinquante cinq mille morts dont 66 mille
rien qu'au mois de mars
un bilan qui ne cesse de croître sous
l'effet du variant p1 particulièrement
virulent test antigénique obligatoire et
quarantaine demandé pour tous les
passagers en provenance du brésil c'est
le nouveau protocole en vigueur depuis
ce week end
j'entendais le ministre dira que le
droit ne permettait pas de suspendre à
bon et bien le rôle de la politique
justement c'est de transformer le droit
lorsqu'ils ne répondent pas à la
nécessaire protection des français
il ya une chose que nous n'avons pas
fait c'est suivre c'est suivre vos
préconisations vous avez écrit au
président de la république en 2020 pour
le conseiller de prescrire l'hydroxyte
lockheed et je vous signale que le
brésil est le pays qui a le plus
prescrit
enfin il faut quand même avoir un peu de
rigueur je les trouve quand même le
gouvernement très léger aussi léger
qu'un string brésilien
l'agencé américaine du médicament a
annoncé le décès par thrombose d'une
personne ayant reçu une dose du vaccin
gens c'est une autre est dans un état
critique
au total six personnes âgées de 18 à 48
ans présentait des symptômes de
thrombose cérébrale
nous avons donc décidé de suspendre
jusqu'à nouvel ordre tous les vols entre
le brésil et la france
dans un tweet les autorités sanitaires
américaines annoncent examiné les
données concernant six cas américain
signaler d'un type rare et grave de
caillots sanguins chez des individus
après avoir reçu le vaccin
il faut sécuriser en fait celles et ceux
qui souhaitent venir en france et qui
traversent la méditerranée vous voulez
vous voulez qu'on fasse quoi dans les
journaux de la question voulons sans
appel à l'immigration
il voulait qu'on y met des mitraillettes
et que tout ce qui arrive non mais c'est
quoi l'excellent surnom adi granov nous
recommande donc une pause dans
l'utilisation du vaccin par prudence
suite à ces annonces le groupe
pharmaceutique johnson and johnson a
pris la décision de retarder le
déploiement de son vaccin en europe je
sais qu'ici en étant assez news ce sont
des sujets délicats 1 va pas du tout
avec les sujets sont les bienvenus avec
vous tous les horizons de convoler la
preuve inra citation à la haine raciale
et vous en avez chez vous les élections
régionales et départementales
doivent-elles être maintenu les 13 et 20
juin prochains c'est un oui pour 56% des
vingt-quatre mille mère qui ont répondu
à la consultation du gouvernement on a
un consensus pour le mode joueurs
faisons comme tous les pays européens
assumons nos élections on ne confirme
pas la démocratie vers la question qui
était posée s'était pas maintient pas
maintien c est ce que les conditions de
protocole qui vous sont proposés sont
jouables pour vous et puis 40 % ont dit
non ça veut dire qu'on a quand même
réussi au travers de cette consultation
à montre aussi ce qu'étaient les écueils
des maires il faut il appartient au
gouvernement d'y répondre
il faut vacciner les assesseurs il faut
parce que sinon comment voulez vous
envoyer des gens tenir des bureaux de
vote sans être sécurisé proposé
les élections aient lieu au mois de juin
peut-être en décalant jusqu'au 27 juin
le deuxième tour ce qui était ma
deuxième proposition
il va proposer ça cet après midi à
l'assemblée pour une semaine
supplémentaire
une semaine de vaccination en plus soit
au moins deux millions de personnes
vaccinées
et comme dirait jean castex à compter de
15 jours à thenon eleven imitateurs